wow as
soon as soon as they get the audio fixed
I'll say welcome to everyone out there
in television
land um I brought a few things to start
out with this is still too too much Mike
how's that a little better yeah okay
uh it still sounds pretty loud to me now
uh let's see first of all I got some
some good
news um and actually I don't have any
bad news so nice um I've got um coming
up I've lined up six guest speakers uh
for this course uh especially at the
part where you you're going to be really
tired of listening to me uh in the end
of November I hope you'll you'll still
find me not too boring in the middle of
November but now on um U actually see
what is it two weeks or so from today
the the 28th we'll will'll be our first
guest speaker herb wilf the current
editor of the math monthly will'll talk
then uh can we have this on the screen
um and then on November 18th Jeff Alman
is going to
talk um anyone anyone in computer
science has probably read at least 10 of
Jeff's books uh lesie Lamport will be
talking on on the next day and then Nels
Nelson and then Mar Mary Clair van lunan
the day before
Thanksgiving uh this will be
uh what's wrong with that I'll be oh she
well it'll be on tape um it yeah um
now um Mary CLA sort of wants to wants
to bring you know be able to rebut
anyone else without having a chance of
anybody else El getting getting at her I
guess um now before this uh uh before
these these these talks I'll be I'll be
handing out some examples of things that
these people have written uh that I
think is pretty good and we can and
we'll take we looking at this a little
bit um let me show you something that I
got from herb today actually he's um
it's just it's just a sample of a letter
that he that he sent out to his
editorial board at the math monthly and
he and he's asking for their advice uh
what is your opinion he says please
check one box um and return to me in the
next couple of weeks thanks yes run it
no not appropriate three wilf is losing
his marbles must be the California
Sunshine um I don't know I thought that
was a good example of herb style and
it's a fairly good way to run business
letters if you asked
me okay could could um put it in in um
use it in exercises in the text too I
guess it's an idea let's see other other
things things left over from in the old
business category I found out that there
were that there were um two of the
assignments that you turned in that I
still had uh wanted to show on screen um
even though I promise never to look at L
of c&p again um I did want to show the
the uh just the idea of variety of
sentence style um
as any sentence is okay but if you use
the same style over and over again it
does get repetitive so here we have a
however comma in addition comma so comma
as a result comma thus comma um five
sentences in a row all with the same all
with the same you know short comma and
so on uh you can do much you can do
better by by using variety let's see
here was a I think another one
here um person like to say following we
have the following
inequality we obtain the following
contradicting
inequality now
we pointed out that use of parallelism
is is better than than Variety in some
cases when the parallelism is an
important thing but here but here and
also uh uh here was uh we have the
following relation it seems to be a uh
it seems to be a habit now I'm afraid to
watch my TV films of this for fear that
I have some tick or something some habit
that I repeat over and over again I
probably do that that's probably very
annoying and and uh and as a
professional I should really examine it
and learn it and correct this if I maybe
I say hopefully all the time or
basically or something but um uh when
you when you look at your own writing
look for look for cases where you've uh
where you've gotten into a
rut uh that can be that can make it
boring let's see now let's I I told you
about the book designer let me show you
what what what I got from the book
designer um gave me this uh this picture
here of how the pages were will look so
he so he shows me these this these grids
here where there'll be a running
headline this will be the graffiti in
the middle remember I was talking about
that on Wednesday and then he shows some
sample pages of how the thing's going to
look um and uh and then he sets out
certain things like displays equations
and he you know he puts graffiti in
there to as an example um and uh shows
shows his idea for displays I should
mention that this is a this is a um kind
of a new
idea for for displaying equations it's
popular MIT press um not to Center them
at usually they're centered and uh but
they he said no let's put all the
equations let's let's let's line them
all up um uh usually on the on the same
place where your paragraph indentation
is and that's a sort of a design element
in here so so you run that through with
the the ex sizes have a hanging
indentation of that same amount and and
uh there's you know all it's it's
something that that unifies rather than
than disturbs the having different
different amount everywhere so it's that
so they look for something even though
math math equations have an awful lot of
uh of variety that he want there he
wants some unifying features So He
suggests putting them all over at the at
the point of the ENT but then some of
them of course are lined up on an equal
sign there um so then uh he he uh
sketches out how he would present
algorithm if I had an algorithm I don't
think I do uh he had to give you know
showing various subheads and and
different
and chice of type that would be used
here um and uh now and on tables he he
he specified you know the way he wants
tables he wants these rule lines to be a
heavy rule at the top and another one
below um I I over speaking of rules I
overruled him a little bit he wanted the
table the material inside the table to
be setting a smaller size of type and
and it didn't work right with the
exposition that I'm planning for this
book the table is really just as
important the stuff in the table is just
important everything else and so I
didn't want it to have a smaller type in
there so I I just use regular type and
so on so he anyway he he he first he
sketches this out then he also provides
something that um that that authors
authors usually don't see because uh
they they send this out to some type
setting house and there's all kinds of
uh of of of U of
Arcane um uh specs in here table column
heads 9/10 computer modern c/ LC or
Oiler for mathematical expressions and
numbers FL l/l over calls of words and
you know flush left flush right uh lined
columns and all this all this got uh
garbage I um uh so nine on 10 meant
ninepoint type uh with 10 points between
baselines and I said I'm going to not
going to go down the ninepoint type
things like that but but uh he's you
know I got all these specs and
um and uh that's because I have I'm
doing the type setting of this myself
instead of instead of having it done by
them this now doing it
myself uh means that uh uh I have a lot
better chance of of uh of having
accuracy in the book and I can see how
the how the format are going to break
and things like that uh the uh uh um
this but but it but I didn't want to
give up the
professional um the the professional
things that that book that uh Publishers
provide the designer and the copy edit
so so uh I so I didn't want so so I'm
although I'm I'm doing the type setting
I'm still sending it back to them for
the services that they ordinarily would
provide if somebody else was doing a
type setting so I'm getting the servic
as their editor then the copy the copy
editor is going to look over my thing
and and then I'm going to I'm going to
make the changes suggested by the copy
editor myself
I'm doing this way Barry yeah just out
of curiosity considering all the other
things you might be doing with your time
do you really think that doing your own
type setting is is a win yeah actually
it it takes very little extra time
compared to what I was doing before I I
I don't think that I'm that I'm less
efficient now than I was when I was
working with the uh you know 20 years
ago when things were going on by hand
does that keep I think I'm probably more
efficient pages per day what does that
keep the cost book down and um the cost
of the
um cost of books are what people will
pay uh it has nothing to do with
manufacturing cost uh paperback uh books
sometimes cost more to manufacture than
hard cover uh like the the techbook for
example that that binding that they put
in this the Y roll binding is a hand is
a hand job it's harder to it costs more
to do that than to make the hard cover
but the hard cover sells for about $15
more and and it's because people when
they when they that's a I mean paperback
book means something to uh to the buyer
saying that this this means that we're
we're putting it out closer to cost and
and the bookstore is getting us uh less
of a markup on it and stuff like this um
but it doesn't really mean that
production cost is less it's it's a big
meth is that true for all books or just
books that are very popular such as your
own this the the uh cost of books is is
uh amazingly low to produce them but
they but uh there's many other costs
Market
uh warehousing and things associated
with them getting them getting them out
out there I mean probably more of my
books have been printed in the Soviet
Union than than uh and in China than in
in uh you know in the usest but um I'm
not sure if they ever get to people uh
they they've been printed but I'm not
sure what happens to them afterwards
because the because you go into a
bookstore and you can't find anything uh
um in those places so um uh uh so
there's a lot of other cost you know in
order to do that job well it takes it
takes money too so there so
manufacturing cost is is is a is is
actually a small part of the of the uh
what a publisher does uh also but the
manufacturing C there's a there's a
there's a real neat book you can get in
the bookstore called one book six ways
uh if you're interested in the in the
process of making books and and and this
was an experiment done by the university
presses of America about uh 15 years ago
where they they decided to take a
hypothetical manuscript that they didn't
really any of them wanted to publish but
each one of them put it through their
whole design process and and and and
estimate cost estimates and and uh and
and then um and so they started out with
the same uh manuscript the book on um
gardening uh indoor flowers or something
like that each one you know made a cover
and they and and they produced 16 sample
pages and you can get these these pages
and you can see all the correspondents
that went back and forth between the
different parts of the of the thing and
all the uh estimates for manufacturing
as to how much it was has been a cost
for different options with color and and
uh and putting it together and then and
then I uh you got six different designs
of the book and six different
presentations uh working in different
ways different symbols for for uh
aspects of how much light and and water
a plant should get and things like that
and uh it's really it's really
interesting to read this is just a uh it
was a uh uh they they wanted to compare
the the methods of MIT press North
Carolina press uh Stanford press is in I
think I forgot sort should remember that
one but I there are six different uh uh
houses and and you can see how you know
if you if you want to know what book
publishers do with it after you get a
manuscript this is definitely the best
source it's called one book six ways and
it's a paperback that doesn't cost very
much less than 10
bucks um okay now where was I I was
answering some question have I answered
it no no confused uh face in front Okay
now um I don't want to give the idea
that writing a book is all Agony and
pain but it it um uh there's lots of
there's lots of fun act too you know
when you when actually some things do
work and you and you do get get uh get
pleasure out of it uh but the uh but it
is work and people say how you know how
do you ever write all these books that
you write or something like that and the
answer is one word at a time and and uh
uh and sometimes the words are written
over several times um and so uh you
count the number of words and you and
you realize that it takes you know it's
just um a matter of being of being
systematic about it and um you read you
read about people who do a lot of
writing I guess Jack London for example
uh there's a there's a great
autobiography about him he was quite a
character um turn of the century and you
can visit his house um wolf house up uh
north of Berkeley a little ways um that
burned down uh a few few days after it
was built but it was going to be one of
the grandest houses in
California this was before H was was
around um and uh London um was quite a
character uh but but make a long story
short he he wrote uh thousand words
every day before coming down to talk to
to his family or do anything El else and
he just he just made that a a rule that
he would write a thousand new words in
the um and then when he finished that he
would come and do the rest of his stuff
and and uh that's um you know 365,000
words a year uh then and uh and in the
afternoon he might you know go over old
words and and revise them or something
like that but this was his this was a
sort of a regimen that he carried out
for 20
years and uh a lot of great books came
out of that
okay
um let's see uh I marked this time I'm a
little more prepared uh in so that I can
be talking about things in this there
there are many things that changed
between the before and after of my of
the manuscript but I wanted to point out
sort of orthogonally different things
there the different things that um
different issues that that go on in this
aspect of the of the editing and one of
them was um uh I said that uh as you're
reading this uh one of the main things
you want to do when you're reading when
you're proof reading your stuff is to is
to think of is to try to put yourself in
in the position of the reader uh try to
remember what the reader has been told
so far what the reader might try to
guess what the reader might expect to
find next and so on now this this is a a
hard thing to do you every reader is
different but you want to do that you
want to do your best anyway and um and
and I found for example at the last
sentence here the same thing holds if we
shift the hexagon to any part of P
triangle as I was reading this through
at speed uh it didn't it didn't come
through what what was what what I what
I'm really talking about here and so I
decided I would change the word saying
the same thing holds if we extract such
a hexagon from any other part of
Pascal's Tri instead of shift the
hexagon to um and I and I talk about
such a hexagon instead of the hexagon
because it just wasn't clear uh you know
but that the specifics of this isn't so
important is the general thing is that
as you're reading through try to see if
if what you're if what you're saying
makes sense to the to the reader who who
knows what he knows instead of the
reader who was you when you wrote it and
knew what you knew when you wrote it
that's quite a different person than the
one who's who who who's coming up so uh
although you although you revise um in
order to improve things um revision
should get better and not get and not
just get more more intricate more uh uh
you you can you can revise something to
death and improve something and and you
know improvements are building on they
can only be understood by by
understanding what what was there before
the Improvement uh that's not that's not
so good it's uh the the the ideal result
is to come up with something that seems
so simple that it seems like it never
had to be Rewritten uh this this this
Simplicity this uh um uh instead of
complexity after revision that's a uh
that's a hard hard thing to achieve when
um I looked up um in the dictionary to
find out if you say replace with or
replace by and the dictionary didn't say
uh this just could give no no no uh um
uh help on this so I still so I still
don't know uh but here was a case where
I DEF where I I was
saying okay the identity
re reflecting this is and then I wanted
to change the sentence I say obtain by
replacing K by n minus
k um and that's uh um I was giving a
little more help before it but then I
realized I have by twice in that
sentence by replacing by n min K that's
not so good at it uh have Buy in there
twice and so but I wouldn't say with and
so then I you know so then the answer
was to to to go to a different word by
changing K2 and minus K and then I got
you know that was it okay so uh
replacing now U here was here is
something where I in the
original um there was this displayed
equation and then the and then we were
trying to figure out if it was true or
false now there's a danger in an in
displaying an equation that's false
because people are going to open the
book to that page and they're going to
look there and they're going to say oh
here's a nice Rule and they're going to
and they'll be able to prove that 0
equals 1 and and I'll be I'll be uh be
able to get all kinds of cories
uh from from from it so so um uh so I
wanted to to figure out a way to say
that so it wouldn't look it wouldn't
look uh uh too uh too good so I said is
some such true then it didn't read very
good at when I finally read it at speed
so then I said is this a valid equation
and I say no and then then the original
said for instance when k equals 0 we get
one unal
0 um and now that didn't read well
either when I said we get one unequal
zero
cuz we actually get one equals z we
don't get one une equal to zero so so I
rewrote and said we get one on the left
and zero on the right okay so so now it
it sounded okay when I was writing it
first at at that speed I was writing but
when I was reading it just much was much
better I I needed something else so I
had to go to the other to the other um
the other thing
um okay now so at the um so keeping
trying to keep the reader at at Tempo
and things like that these are the these
are the things that you notice here here
I had to refer to the equation and I
said so minus1 choose k equals this is
always false um I finally uh I had that
that didn't read too well either so I
put quotes around it and this was this
quoted thing was false and finally I put
the word the equation so finally say so
the equation such and such is always
false let's see did that come out how
did that come out now in the in the
actual
after
um here we go so okay so after the
corrections were were made uh but the
right side is zero
because wait a
minute yeah we get one on the left and
zero on the
right
um and uh so the equation such and such
is always false ooh exclamation
point all right
well I per I permit myself one every
once in a while still after all we're
talking about factorials
and
okay
um okay now another another thing that
uh that you find as you're as you're
reading through is that you is is that
you have a chance to to move things
around um present things in that there's
a more logical order than uh than than
what what you had in your original
manuscript and uh so here for example it
say it it
um uh it follows I'm going to talk more
about that it we've already used it
here um and it's not the same as this it
uh the prep the uh the antecedent of a
preposition of a pronoun should be clear
and if you say it follows uh sort of
meaning um you know uh as a consequence
of uh then you have to be awfully
careful that the it isn't confused in
the reader's mind with some other
it um we call it and absorb it so I say
the the identity follows from definition
51 but and then I but but here's the
point I want to get here because both
sides are zero and K less than zero
otherwise um I otherwise there's no
argument so so I have in definition 51 I
I'm I'm giving a proof here and I'm and
I'm talking about first about the case
where K is less than zero second about
the the other case when K is not less
than zero but if you look back at
definition
51 um lo and behold first they consider
the case k greater than or equal Z
second they consider the case k less
than Zer so so if you actually you know
if you're actually looking at definition
51 uh definition which is you're
supposed to sort of have in mind or be
you know there's a reference to it here
um our proof should follow the same
order as as as in there so we should
consider the case k greater than equal Z
first and then do the otherwise case
later I think it it made better
pedagogical sense also to give the uh to
give the highlight of the the the hard
part of the proof first and get over
with and then then wind it up quick um
instead of easing into the trivial case
of the proof especially when that was
the second part of the definition so so
here was this this you know two arrows
meant uh uh really it's better to change
this
around okay now next kind of a problem
that I that I have here by the way Paul
are you taking notes today or Tracy okay
this one
okay now the next kind of a problem is
um something that um occurs only uh when
you're when you're near the end of the
where you're near the end of the uh uh
process uh and you and you assume that
and you're going to pages that are
people are going to read and you've got
the text okay but now I found out that
there was a bad page break here in the
middle of a displayed formula I'm
starting a derivation the top of the
next page uh the thing the thing
continues see at the bottom of that page
another one is um uh also I said open up
I wanted a little more open uh but uh
more space between lines but but that
one also uh is you know is so so two so
these Pages both broke in a bad place so
so defin so so definitely I wanted uh
this to this to be in the middle of a
page you know if I can solve the problem
and get a nice page break to come in
here U between you know before those of
us who tend not to discover such slick
proofs incidentally I think that was or
and I think that was originally tend to
not discover uh but that's
okay maybe it's okay but um uh anyway
tend not to disc discover the Slick Pro
that's the that that that would be nice
if that came at the beginning of a page
because then we'd see this whole display
and this next one would would fall
nicely too so what I need is something
more I got to do something more on the
previous line I got to think of
something interesting to do now now uh
as I said in the old days when I wasn't
doing the type setting um the page
makeup man would would think of of
something interesting to say for me by
displaying some equation that he would
just choose U that he thought would be
suitable for display and that would make
up a few more lines and then uh and then
that would move move the copy
around um uh now um however when I found
I was types setting myself and I started
doing volume two of the art of computer
programming that was my first experience
with this it was in 1980 um I found uh
cases where for example I I needed about
12 lines of copy on one page so that on
the next page I could get the algorithm
and the table shows that goes with the
algorithm in the flowchart all facing
pages and it would all look nice
otherwise I'd have the thing split and
and a person would have to page back and
forth in order to check the thing and so
I needed I needed to figure out um 12
lines of something interesting to say on
the previous page well so that's a nice
spur to research I mean uh so I said so
I I thought about a little bit you know
and I and I finally I came up with with
a with actually I think about 20 lines
of of good stuff and I had to cut some
other paragraph back because U but you
know this is an incentive to to prove
more mathematics if you have to say if
you have to say something um interesting
now in this case I couldn't think of
anything more interesting to say here so
I did the the dis the so I I monkey
around with the displayed equation and
so on this on on this page I decided to
take this long display and and um and
make it more expository by breaking it
into four four lines and say by Symmetry
and so on and and uh you know sort of
clinching the argument by by saying it
by saying it long hand instead of by
saying it shorthand and uh now um uh
this uh the reader won't mind having
this extra explanations in here and it
gave me just the amount of space that I
need so that when I get to the to the
next page uh and behold here it goes uh
it comes out nicely and then the next
the next one breaks also at a nice place
okay so um uh uh twilling around with
displays helps helps a lot as far as as
far as page breaking concerned and this
is one of the advantages that math
mathematicians have over people who
aren't writing with a lot of displayed
math uh is that we that there is a lot
of extra flexibility here if somebody's
uh if you got a novel that's that's
already been written by somebody and you
want to avoid a um you want to make it
so that you you don't get a line that
stands you know stands all by itself at
the end of a chapter or something like
this um uh it's not so easy you got to
you got to fudge some of the paragraphs
make them looser or something or or
tighter something like that it's much
easier with
mathematic
okay uh next
point the next point the rises in uh
mathematical Exposition if you try to
use a dash um a dash can can can be
confusing with a minus sign and uh so uh
although linguistically a dash might
have been been fine there um it doesn't
work out too well so I put a coal in and
then I said by the way we have then in
here so so the let's read the sentence
we found it by repeatedly expanding the
B binomial coefficient with the smallest
lower index Dash 53 then 2 42 then 31
then two zero no commas were necessary
it was sort of fast then but now I got
to slow it down in order to take out the
dash and put so and put another word in
here so I say first 53 comma then 42
then 3 1 then two 0 then it wasn't then
wasn't so uh you know it wasn't um
uh so ambiguous and uh that the dash can
certainly be confused with a minus sign
there are three kind there are four
kinds is it let's see there's a yeah
there's four kinds there's a
hyphen
um is a is a short is a short symbol
then there's an N Dash and there's an M
Dash and there's a minus sign which is
somewhere in
between um so a
hyphen um
uh is uh something that occurs like this
repeating here that little line after
repeat there see so that's uh that's the
case for hyphen an N Dash is is longer
than a hyphen and it tends to be used
when you're talking about a range of
things like if you're saying Pages 10 to
to 18 that's an N Dash that goes in
there um and uh an M Dash is what you
use in the sentence um for
Dash and uh a minus sign is what you use
in a formula they're four they are four
different symbols and they um and uh
they all come out looking about the same
on a typewriter but but uh when you get
into when you get into print um there
there are these four in fact in the old
days they used to have they have used to
have longer and longer dashes I mean
Jonathan Swift he would he he had uh uh
you know the length of the dashes uh
would would have importance in his
poetry
okay let's
see
um now let's
see H here's what here's a case where I
had to correct the mathematics as I was
reading it through I you can also you
know not only catch uh errors of English
errors of uh typography and things like
this but you can also see that your your
mathematics is slipping uh it helps to
you know gives you a chance to doing
that and uh and here I'm talking about 0
to the 0o and um and and I'm trying to
make make a point that uh 0 to the 0o um
is definitely equal to one and um and
I'm talk saying the functions x to the 0
and 0 to the X have different limiting
values when X approaches
zero um now as I'm reading through this
I realized that that's not correct if x
goes to Z through negative values uh
then 0 to the x is undefined and so I
and so I I you know so I re re I change
the sentence to when X decreases to zero
and then and then it becomes correct
then it's not but then it's clear what
the mistake is yeah I say well but this
is a mistake uh it wasn't my mistake it
was their
mistake
okay
um okay let's see
um I say and here um oh uh another case
of reading at speed I um uh here's a
sentence and when x equal minus1 instead
when I when I read it over again I
didn't it wasn't clear to me what what
it what what this instead meant and so I
changed it to instead of plus
one um didn't hurt to add this to tell
what it was instead of in minus one
instead of plus one I insert the
Redundant plus there in order to in
order to emphasize the contrast between
minus1 and + one uh and um and put that
in so so there's a a trick of uh again
of of exposition for at
speed the um uh the table here um as I'm
talking this sentence I found as I was
reading it that I used see if you can
catch what I was doing here let's look
more closely at the values of n k and
chose K1 N is a negative integer one or
to approach these values is to use the
addition La 57 to fill in the values
that lie above the numbers table in
table 5.1 what was the problem that I
noticed as I read that
sentence multiv we'll take you yeah it's
multivalue good good bar um yeah I used
values all the time uh in there that's
the that's so I changed this to entries
so you know they're table entries so
okay
um uh now here's a point that I wanted
to make the other day forgot and it's I
think it's kind of important about
present
tense
um uh but where is the reference wait a
minute oh okay appeared this okay now
here's a sentence um says all of these
numbers are familiar indeed the rows and
Columns of this table appeared as
columns in table 5.1 but minus the minus
Signs Now
um okay I did several things to fix this
up first of all I changed this semicolon
to a period so it's all these numbers
are familiar period indeed the rows and
columns and then I say of table
5.2 appeared as as columns in table 5.1
minus and minus Signs Now um
so um this is to stress parallel is I I
talk about table 5.2 versus table 5.1 it
makes it more parallel but but here I'm
focusing on the word appeared uh yes
they they appeared in in that table we
saw before but they also are still there
I mean that take if you go back there
it's still there now and and
uh I like Skeptics bar that's good okay
um
um we have some graffiti by skeptic uh
in one of the um now uh okay so
uh and and especially what you should
you've got to use present tense about
when you're talking about a fact that's
sort of that's sort of Timeless so you
don't say 2 plus 2 was four you know we
we we we proved that 2 plus 2 was four
in fourth grade we proved it that 2 plus
2 equals 4 because it's we it's it's a
fact it's it's it's something that's
true for all time and so you always use
present tense for facts um and U and in
this case u i i i i I think um you know
we the the use of present and past uh
know we we looked at at at the things
that that appear in table in the table
but they still appear there they're
still
there okay
um so so uh I had comments about using
using uh um tenses in in in a long paper
where you can use future for something
that's coming up later um and pass for
things that have done happened before
but still still if they happen before uh
and they're still true you still use
present tense for them and uh and I
added to the to the note something I
didn't say in class that day when that
is uh when you're using these you can
also use verbs you can also use
adjectives talking about about duration
you can say we just proved it instead or
we proved this long ago in chapter 1 or
something like that uh and we're going
to going to prove something soon or
we're going to prove something at um um
in in a minute uh you got you got these
extra little phrases to to uh convey how
far a distance there is back and forth
that you that uh uh that go with this
idea of of time if you're considering
your your discourse with the reader as a
function as a function of time if if the
whole paper is in present tense uh you
don't have a chance to to use those but
you have to say above or far above or
something like that and you still do
something like that I
guess yeah that previous table is any
reason why you don't give the
number
um uh well uh I I don't know I have to
write another macro but uh
um uh the table was fairly close back
and and and they are consecutive through
a chapter but but if it were if it were
if were remote reference I
would I I would I would give a page
number doesn't seem to make sense to
both number the tables and num and refer
to the page um yeah
you you could
well
um I see this table and the table on
page on on the table on page 20111 or
something like that could be done
yeah but uh but this uh it's yeah cross
references are um a problem but I'm not
going to do this with every equation I
mean I I give a lot of equs by number
and and I'm not going to and and uh it's
going to it would really slow down the
whole Exposition if I if if I had to
give a page number for all that um
easier to find equations because there's
so many you can see a page and any page
will have one on it then you know which
way to go but tables seem to occur so
rarely that you can flip many pages and
not know where that's right where you
are I uh just something that I saw only
once in an Algebra text I used was all
the tables were numbered um in a 5 312
for chapter 5 page
312 Ah that's interesting that's neat
that's like freeway exits that uh you
know this is ex ex exit exit 182 they do
that I don't know if they do that in
California but they do that a lot in in
East
yeah
okay yeah go by the kilometer post to by
the page number
okay sounds like a good
idea
um here's a place where I decided to
transpose two parts of the text because
the argu because because the uh I I
decided that the uh I wanted to say two
things but the the reader wanted this
wanted to know the second one first the
thread of the the thread of the
discussion I I'm just presenting a
formula here and then I and the first
thing the reader just wants to know I
decided is why the formula is true and
and secondly that the formula is is
really
useful um um I can uh I you can you can
count on him to think that it's going to
be useful for a minute anyway and then
you can then you can stress its
usefulness later on in applications and
so I decided to switch these two parts
around and so and so um uh let's let's
look at before and after here so I
present this this law here people whove
taken 260 have this rule called negating
the upper
index um which is a transformation and
binomial coefficients okay and it says
it's particularly valuable because it
holds without any restriction per n
except that the lower index must be an
integer so that the binomial
coefficients are defined close par end
so here we're here we presented the law
but we don't we might be hanging saying
I'm not sure I believe it uh but then um
immediately we're talking about it being
valuable because of such of why it's
valuable except for a you know so we
weren't quite ready for that much yet um
uh so uh and and the name of it and so
on so and then it's then finally come to
it is easily proved since then we give
this this um uh and I got to talk about
breaking displayed formulas later but
this didn't fit on the line obviously
and so we have to we have to do
something about about making that in in
in two lines well uh so
rewrite to try to present it
better so here it goes general rule
uh which has been motivated by all these
numbers being familiar is easily Pro
since such and such happens when k grer
equal zero and both sides are zero and K
less than zero now I get to now I get to
to to uh press in the point that this is
really worth knowing in case it slipped
by it's particularly valuable because it
holds without any
restriction of source
what of course
is that a malapropism how let change
thec
um had had dinner with my editor the
other we talking about Farmers for some
reason we the phrase weeded and reap
came up in our in
our
discussion uh I got a I got a very I got
a very good editor okay now um okay of
course the lower index was so all right
so
um um now also that parenthetical remark
was was was removed from the tail end of
the previous sent the original sentence
had it there before the period except
that the lower index and so on but this
this putting it in a separate sentence
keeps it less keeps it less complicated
what we're doing we get to the period we
we actually said something then we're
ready for a little exception to the rule
um then uh the transformation is called
negating the upper index but how can we
remember this important form us so okay
now
um now uh here's a um another advantage
of of of the idea of of graffiti uh I
was able to throw in a few places U
suggestions that it's a good time now to
go to the end of the chapter and look
for look at the certain exercise that
everybody uh that everybody you know
would would be wise to warm up with on
this
point and um uh okay so that's ghost
written graffiti here and there uh this
is real graffiti down here this is
reassuring but it can also be
frustrating so okay now another
mathematical point on this page um I had
a formula here where I where the right
hand side was minus a fraction and that
minus sign could get lost there next to
the fraction bar so I changed the I so I
changed the equation and wrote r/2 minus
K instead of K - r/2 on the left hand
side I I I get a find identity and
without the minus sign on the right okay
so you get a chance to rearrange
mathematical formulas to make them more
easily read of course when I do that I
have to change it here too because I'm
referring to the factor and I got to
remember that you know that that if I
made some references to it elsewhere I
have to have to convert those references
question yeah uh on the integrals that
you have there I'm curious as to the
convention some people put
the uh low
L bound to the left the lower limit
instead of sometimes okay there's
there's some people like like this way I
never saw that on that side really no I
I mean I what like this yes really where
do you come from is that
so hey I didn't know that
one oh okay I so I know saying the
convention is either on the bottom that
would really that would really mix up
with stuff that comes up in front in
front there I think that would that
would uh but but putting it putting it
way under and way over is a is a house
sty you know it's a style that you adopt
throughout a book for displays on
integral signs you decide whether or not
you have have uh limits at the right of
an integral or or up and and bottom this
one takes more more space but if you
don't have very many integral signs it
might might be easier to easier to read
them takes less horizontal
space it takes less horizontal space
right which so you can you can you can
uh get long you get wider formulas in
there yeah yeah that's true and for
multiple integrals things like that
disconnect
right okay um I CH I did edit this to
say I wanted to use Alpha instead of a
here the the a was was conflicting with
something else in the uh in the text and
I didn't realize when I wrote the draft
I I patched this in later so I changed
the letter Alpha there but that's
another point uh let's see another
advantage of graffiti is that I could
every once in a while quote an original
Source when somebody discovered when
some now this is livet writing here when
he discovered the he he he discovered
trinomial
coefficients and um and so uh I mean
he's talking about um uh you know
thinking cogitating here you know and
miraculous rule mirab regam you know for
the for the for the coefficients of a
power not only by binomial but also the
trinomial and so on into a polinomial
and and comprehensive and so on you know
as possible to assign a number of
coefficients so he's discovering the
trinomial theorem here I thought that
was a nice graffiti to put in uh because
this is a letter that he wrote to beri
when he when he discovered this and uh
and so I get to use this and every once
in a while I have a a uh found where
where the uh the first occurrence of a
of an important uh thing in mathematics
is recorded in it's in the original
language
okay you site that it's yeah yeah no you
see this unfortunately this uh the
graffiti macro doesn't have a a way of
of uh of going to the next page and I
didn't know where it would fall on a
page you know and so and so uh uh this
and everything is changing here this is
my very first output so I so uh some of
the graffiti will fall in the wrong
place but when you finally get the when
when you finally get the real the real
one uh yeah title it's it's got a
reference to livits and his and his uh
and then the 86 will be the the letter
to beri on such and such a day found in
such and such a collection of Li nits is
shrift and do you have some of the gra
Ling off on to the other page is that
why you have them facing one another um
actually that never happens uh they're
always short enough that that uh that
they can be positioned but I have to
position that by hand why did you choose
to have the graffiti
facing one another on the respective oh
the um uh the book designer chose that
he decided that that would be the better
the best way to do it I think it I think
it's a win after looking at it but it
surprised me when I first saw his his
idea okay uh but this is a this is a
a aspect of the book style that I I
guess
uh uh comment a little about that that
is um
um I never wrote a book that had that
had a graffiti column before and um so
as I'm writing the book I'm trying to
get the feeling for what it what it's
like to live in that kind of a world and
what what uh how can the book be better
uh uh because this is there uh and not
uh I don't want to overdo it but I want
to find you know find the things that
this allows me to do that I couldn't do
before and uh some of them seem to
definitely be wins and as like as you go
through and here I am in chapter five
I'm finally realizing something you know
that that that I can put into the
previous chapters and you and and when I
was writing the first few pages of
chapter one I had no idea what this was
going to be like I was just I was just
playing around um and that's one of the
reasons why you rewrite is because this
is like why you reite an operating
system you you find out that as you're
using the operating system uh you want
other features that you didn't think of
when you when you were designing it and
it's the same with with the book you you
want you you you learn how to you sort
of develop a style for for that
particular book each book is a bit
different um and you get to learn the
style if you're writing a novel you get
to learn your characters they they they
take a their personality blossoms uh as
you as you uh think about them more uh
the guy who illustrated The Textbook
said that uh that um this lion that he
was drawing um he he kept learning more
about the lion as he you know after and
and he would go through a whole pass of
doing 40 drawings of it and then then
come through again and then he would
know he he could really Vis this became
a a sort of a person in his mind these
things take shape in the same way a
style of a of a document takes shape uh
as you as uh as you write
it okay um well I got time for one
more um and that is about breaks between
um no let's leave that till Friday
covered a lot today any other
questions
okay I I'm planning to have a a homework
that you will enjoy doing next week but
I haven't figured out how to do it
yet
e